this video we're going to introduce a
couple of words to help talk about the
relationship between sines and cosines
or different sinusoids that have the
same frequency but a different timing
relationship so what I've shown here is
a plot of a cosine and a sine wave and
the axis here is in theta in the angle
the radiant angle of the cosine or sine
now I can label these but PI over 2
represents a 90 degrees change pi is a
180 degrees this is 270 degrees and this
is 360 degrees those are two equivalent
scales for the the angle the angle axis
in degrees or in radians now one thing
we notice here is that sine a cosine
they look the same but they don't
overlap if I change this to a time if I
change this to a time axis what I can
say is that the the the cosine wave
reaches its peak at time equals zero and
the sine peak the sine wave reaches its
peak at a later time this is increasing
time going this way so the the sine is
delayed compared to the cosine the peak
here is delayed here if I go down and
look at these two peaks we see the same
relationship this sine peak in orange is
behind is delayed from the cosine so
when we have this timing relationship
between two periodic waves what we say
is in this case we say that the cosine
leads the sine-wave
and the amount of lead is the difference
between these two points and we could
say the lead is 270 minus 180 in this
case be 90 degrees so we say that cosine
leads sine by 90 degrees now I can take
exactly the opposite point of view if I
actually measure where the sine is
relative to cosine and I say it's behind
then we would say it lags so the phrase
we hear would be sine lags cosine by 90
degrees so that's the term lead and lag
that's what those mean now these terms
apply this idea of a delay this only
applies when these frequencies are the
same if the frequencies are different
the relationship between the two
waveforms changes all the time so we use
the word leading lag when we know that
the two signals we are talking about are
exactly the same frequency one thing I
want to be able to do is Express sines
and cosines in terms of each other so if
I have a sine wave could I actually
express this orange curve as a cosine
wave how would I do that
so what I notice if I look at the value
of sine right here and this is sine at
90 degrees or sine at PI over 2 if I
look at this value here what I notice is
that this has the same value which is
the peak of one cosine has the same
value the peak of 1 but 90 degrees
earlier 90 degrees before because it's a
leading function so this suggests a
conversion factor any time I I pick out
a value of the sine if I look back 90
degrees I'll see the same value for
cosine so I can write something like
this I can say that sine of theta equals
the cosine of theta
- 90 degrees if I go out to some value
let's say they're on the sine curve and
if I back up 90 degrees like that
I'll read the same value on the cosine
curve so those will give these two
functions will give me the same number
so I can write this identity in reverse
also if I have a cosign if I'm riding
along on this cosine wave what I notice
is if I if I let's say I'm right here
I'll notice I have the my peak value
here and if I added if I went later in
time or if I added 90 degrees I would
have the same value on that orange sine
curve so if I look here on cosine I want
to know what that is in terms of a sine
function if I add 90 degrees to the
argument the sine function will give me
the same value so what that says is
cosine theta equals sine of theta plus
90 so these are two identities we can
use this to convert something expressed
as a sign into a cosine or vice versa
now I want to show you two more
identities that are actually pretty
useful and here what I have is I've
sketched on in dashed lines the negative
of the orange curve so this is a
negative sine wave you can see if the
opposite of the the original sine wave
we had so now I have the case here where
the cosine is trailing or lagging the
negative sign right it comes later in
time right there so cosine lags negative
sign and what I'll do is I'll write the
same sort of identities here but in
terms of this negative sign and those
come out like this cosine of theta
equals minus sign so that's the dashed
one of theta minus 90 degrees so what
that means if I want to know the value
of cosine
and I can flip that around the same way
and I can say that negative sine of
theta equals cosine of theta plus 90
that's the same identity but in Reverse
if I want to know the value of negative
sine I just take that argument I add it
I advance it by 90 degrees and take the
cosine it'll have the same value so this
identity and this identity are pretty
useful to have around this one allows us
to convert sines and cosines together
this pair here is useful for moving
minus signs around so that's what I
wanted to say about lead and lag these
are sort of slang or jargon the
nicknames of the relationship between
two different waveforms of the same
frequency but different phase timing
different phase delay and then we worked
out some some identities that are kind
of useful to have around to be able to
convert these these two waveforms from
one to the other and back